[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I now introduce
you to Rowen Somerville.
[APPLAUSE]
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: Thank
you very much, [INAUDIBLE]..
That was an amazing
introduction.
You can stop me anytime--
really lovely.
Can everyone hear me?
All right.
Thank you very much
for having me--
just breathing for a moment.
I'm in the heart of the beast at
the moment, the starry dynamo.
Here we are at the
heart of Google.
That's very exciting for me.
I just wonder-- my
publisher is on holiday
at the moment with 14 teenagers,
and they're around 16 years
old.
And he said to me, not one
of them has bought a book.
It's incredible, isn't it?
I wonder if you're responsible.
But that's not fair
at all, actually.
But whether books
continue to exist
or don't, what will
remain is narrative.
And I've been looking at talks,
like TED talks and Google
Talks, trying to get an idea
of what one is meant to do.
And one thing they
tend to do is have
an argument like
there's something
that I'm going to
convince you of--
something that I'm going
to change your mind about.
And that's not the way
it's going to be here.
If there's any
ambition I have, it's
simply to inspire a
few ideas and thoughts.
And if there's any
ideology I have I
suppose it's against dualism--
against this or that--
right or wrong.
I mean, particularly
in a context like this,
this is a very difficult area--
Palestine, Israel--
Jews, Muslims--
Protestant, Catholic.
I'm not talking about
Protestant, Catholic,
but there's some
subject matters that
just immediately close you down
and rise up the tribal hackles.
And as a result of which
I've noticed that TED Talks,
for instance, and
lots of other things,
just avoid them for reasons
because people kick up fuss.
But if there's any ideology I've
got, it's against easy dualism
because I spent
seven or eight years
of my life looking at history.
I'm not a historian.
I just went and asked everyone
I could find what happened.
And the only thing I
can tell you for sure
is that history is
a messy business
the closer you get to it.
But when I say
neither this nor that,
it doesn't mean that I'm
going to eject-- live
in some sort of relativist
world, where oh, well, we
can't tell where reality
is, so everything's right.
No, just put your
hand on your heart,
and you will feel it beating.
And surely, that's true.
And mine's really beating
quite hard at the moment.
But surely that's a truth--
your heart, my heart is
pumping oxygenated blood
through our bodies
and particularly
to the brain, which is
giving us this consciousness
to be able to understand.
That's a truth I can hold on to.
But to speak about this story--
because what I'm really
here is to tell you a story,
and to the best of my
ability, it's true.
And it begins in Tel Aviv
in 2001, June the 1st.
Loads of young people are
standing outside a nightclub.
And I mean young.
They're teenagers.
It's teen night outside.
It's teen night at the nightclub
in the Dolphinarium in Tel
Aviv.
It's a warm, beautiful night.
They're all gathering
in order to get inside.
And most of these
people are former--
they lived in-- they come
from the former Soviet Union.
And their parents have emigrated
as a result of Israel's efforts
to bring more people with
some sort of Jewish connection
into Israel.
And these are their
sons and daughters.
And they are all
together on this night
to have a brilliant
night's dancing, kissing,
who knows what will happen.
There is one person there
who's a little bit older.
He's 22.
His name is Saeed Hotari.
And he doesn't come--
he's not from the
former Soviet Union.
He's from a place
14 kilometers away.
He's never been to Tel
Aviv before that moment.
He's looking around
with wonder, I imagine.
And just before 11 o'clock, the
doors of the nightclub open.
And most of the boys
are letting the girls
go in free because girls
get in free before 11:00.
And at the point at which the
crowd is at its most dense,
Saeed Hotari screams
the name of his god
and sets off a bomb packed with
shrapnel and ball bearings,
immediately killing 22 people--
23, if we include him--
and injuring hundreds.
And the devastation
is appalling.
And I've spent a long time
looking at the photographs
and whatever.
And the only thing I can say is
that the cement area literally
runs with blood.
This sets off what is called
a mass casualty incident.
It's a sad reflection on
Israel's recent history--
Israel only has a
recent history--
that Israel's probably
better than any other country
in dealing with a mass
casualty incident.
That's where emails go out.
All the telephone
communications are cleared.
Texts immediately go to doctors.
Parking is cleared in areas.
High school volunteers are
there to push trolleys around.
It's amazingly organized.
And all the nearby
hospitals are alerted.
A man called [INAUDIBLE] is
the trauma specialist who's
in charge of the
nearest hospital.
And he starts dealing with
the extraordinary number
of horribly injured
teenagers who were arriving.
Now let's just look at
how they're injured--
blast.
Blast is the modern
expression of warfare.
At one stage, we were
throwing rocks at each other.
We made weapons-- iron weapons,
bronze weapons, swords, arrows,
muskets, rifles, guns.
Today, it's basically blasts.
Bullets aren't over, but
it's basically blasts.
And the nature of
blasts is it has
a peculiar pattern of injury.
Not to go into it too
much, but just so you hear
and understand a bit about
it, primary blast injury
is from the blast wave.
And that will attack anything
with fluid in it-- your eyes,
your ears, digestive areas.
It's very, very difficult
to deal with medically.
Then the secondary
blast injury, that
accounts for 85% of blasts.
That's all the
shrapnel or whatever.
And it goes on and on.
There's an air blast
that can blow things off.
The injuries are
enormous and varied.
And they need a large selection
of medical specialties, all at
once sometimes--
trauma specialists,
burn specialists--
I can hardly ever pronounce
it, but otolaryngologists--
ocular specialists.
A large number of
different specialties
are all there, sometimes
on the same patient.
And if we go-- another
of the hospitals nearby,
there is a man, who I'm going
to focus on called Yaacov Lavie.
And he's a cardiologist.
He's a cardiac surgeon.
And like so many Israelis, but
particularly a cardiac surgeon,
he hasn't really looked at the
time at all the historical--
looked at the
political situation.
He's just focused on
being a cardiac surgeon.
He's a nice guy.
He is very-- the word
pro-Palestinian isn't
quite right, but
he's very sympathetic
to the Palestinian cause.
He's a left-winger, but he's
not involved in everything.
Because one of the things
that isn't generally used
in post blasts--
what's generally not
needed is heart surgery.
Heart surgery is pretty
much a peacetime activity
unless you get
something in your heart.
And so he, who is used to
being the center of activity,
is sitting there with
his head in his hands
experiencing what he described
to me as rage because standing
there--
there are teenagers coming
in with battlefield injuries.
And then just down
from where he is
is a ward he's
responsible for, which
is full of all the
end-stage cardiac patients--
people waiting for
a heart transplant.
Now I'm going to stop
with this horrific scene
that you can imagine across
four or five hospitals
around Tel Aviv, and let's
just go a few hours later
to Jerusalem.
Jerusalem is only
40 kilometers away--
44 kilometers away.
I mean, I thought when I went
to that part of the world,
I imagined it would be much
bigger because of the sheer
concentration of
narratives-- let alone,
the biblical ones I was given
growing up, but then all the--
[INAUDIBLE] it's tiny.
It's the size of
Wales pretty much.
There, in Jerusalem, let's see
a man called Mazen Joulani,
He's a Palestinian.
He lives in East Jerusalem.
He's got absolutely nothing to
do with what happened the night
before.
What he has to do with is his
three children, his wife, being
a pharmacist, trying
to live a normal life--
particularly difficult as a
Palestinian amidst the Second
Intifada in East Jerusalem.
He wakes up, says goodbye
to his kids, goes to work,
has his whole day--
no doubt hearing
about that terrific bomb that
happened the night before.
On his way back home,
he does the equivalent
of stopping off for a pint.
He goes and has a cup of tea
with his mates at the cafe.
Everyone goes in
to watch the news.
Mazen Joulani has been
hearing the news all day.
Maybe he sits outside.
Maybe he's smoking a cigarette.
Maybe he's drinking
a cup of tea.
A car draws up,
and a man gets out.
The witnesses say it
was an Israeli settler.
He walks up to Mazen Joulani.
He doesn't know him,
and he shoots him
in the neck as a random
reprisal for what
had happened the night before.
A few hours later, Mazen Joulani
is lying in a hospital bed.
His family's all around him.
There's massive bandages
around his neck.
But otherwise the heart monitor
is going beep, beep, beep,
beep, and he looks OK.
And a doctor is telling
his family that he's dead,
but his heart is beating.
And the doctor's saying,
yeah, but he's brain dead.
Outside the room is a
transplant coordinator.
She has the exquisitely
difficult task
of going to the family
who, a few hours ago--
their son, their husband,
their father, their brother
was fine--
and asking for his heart.
That's hard under
normal circumstances
if it happens in Dublin,
if it happens wherever.
But there, in Jerusalem, in the
midst of the Second Intifada,
where it was
culturally pressured
to not help the other
side on any level at all,
it's very, very
difficult indeed.
But the thing about a heart
transplant, as opposed
to, say, the kidney--
you can get the kidney out
of a recently dead person
no problem.
A heart needs a
still-beating donor,
and that makes it very, very
rare because only about 2%
of deaths are going to be
brain damage deaths or deaths
that would allow a
still-beating donor.
And then you've got to get
the heart when the person is
seemingly still alive.
They are alive.
I mean, until 1967
when the first heart
transplant was done,
the definition of life
was your beating heart.
Just because your
brain's scrambled
doesn't mean that
you're not alive.
I mean, a tree doesn't have
a brain, and it is alive.
But what the transplant
coordinator said
was that she didn't
have anything to do.
She went up, and Mazen's
mom said, take the heart.
And she knew it was going to
an Israeli Jew, the tribe that,
as far as she was concerned,
had killed her husband--
not all the Jews
everywhere but as far as--
within the context of her mind.
But she said it doesn't
matter whether it's
a Christian, a Jew, or Muslim.
It doesn't matter who it is.
Just save someone else's life.
So go back to Yaacov
Lavie, our cardiac surgeon.
He's still sitting there
with his hand in his head.
The phone rings.
It's Tamara Ashkenazi, who is
the head of the transplant, who
goes, we've got a heart
for Yitzhak Cohen.
Now Lavie got to know all the
people in the end-stage heart
unit because although Israel
has the ability, the know-how,
the technical surgical
expertise, incredibly
high standards of
medicine, and the money
to offer its citizens
heart transplants,
there is an acute
shortage of hearts.
One of the reasons is, because
as I was already describing,
they are rare.
On the other reason, there
was the problem that about 10%
of the population could be
described as ultra orthodox.
It's people with the
hats and the locks.
And they want the hearts
if they need them.
But also, religiously,
they say they
can't be donors, so that brings
down the percentage, as well.
There's lots of
difficult things.
And then in this
country, in the UK,
in France, there's
a special thing.
And if you had a
heart, and it didn't--
you couldn't find
anywhere for it to go,
it would go to a nearby country.
But Israel's nearby
countries are not
going to send them hearts.
They're going to send them
shells, missiles, whatever.
So there's an acute
shortage of hearts.
And here is a man, Yitzhak
Cohen, who Lavie, the surgeon,
has got to know pretty well.
And he's dying slowly.
And he admitted to me
with his characteristic--
this is a wide
brush of a stroke,
but characteristic
Israeli bluntness.
And he goes, yeah, I was looking
at the newspapers checking out
tragedies, wondering if there'd
be a heart for me before I die.
He's got two kids.
He knows which way he's going.
He can hardly walk anymore.
And what's he wanting?
It's not so bad.
He just wants to survive.
I mean, I think
it's 16th century,
the great philosopher
Spinoza tried to find--
is there anything that
links all living beings?
And he came up with
proposition seven.
It pertains of an
organism to exist.
We all want to exist, and that's
all Yitzhak Cohen wanted to do
was exist.
And guess what?
His heart is there for him.
Mazen Joulani's family
is giving his heart.
And Lavie comes in,
and he goes, Cohen,
I've got a heart for you.
And immediately, this sets off
a whole set of different things
that kick in.
He immediately tells his
family, stops eating.
He gets prepped.
And then another
group of surgeons
goes off to Jerusalem
to extract the heart--
a cardiectomy.
This is something
I've witnessed,
and it's a really harsh
thing to watch because there
is a patient at the beginning.
And at the end,
they're lying there,
a corpse with their chest open
as if vultures had been there.
But it's an amazing act
of generosity, to give.
Anyway, what
happens from then on
is what is probably the
most dramatic medical thing
that I know of, which
is a heart transplant.
So the one team goes off.
Lavie is there with
Cohen, who is now sedated.
And he's in constant
contact with the team
that's taking it out.
They don't know that
the heart is good
until they actually open up
the chest and look at it.
Is anyone really squeamish?
I have friends-- oh, you are.
That was what I--
so I won't go into
too many details,
but you can tell it's really
good until you look at it.
And then Lavie isn't going
to open up the chest of Cohen
until he knows it's worth doing.
And then he'll prep.
He'll attach Cohen's
diseased heart
to a heart bypass machine.
But he won't take it out.
And he'll get the call
saying the heart looks good.
And then it zooms over.
And he just waits for an hour.
And there's just
one thing to do.
He's not going to
snip out the heart
until he's got the
new one next to him
because there's no going
back at that stage.
When he has the new one next
to him, he opens the box.
He looks at it,
checks it, and then he
makes the five cuts on
the five great vessels--
if I can remember them--
superior vena cava,
inferior vena cava,
aorta, pulmonary vein,
pulmonary artery.
I think that's five--
takes it out and puts
in the new heart.
And then sews, sews, sews-- and
the last one being the aorta.
And at a certain
point, then you release
the cross clamp
and blood fills in.
Now just before he does that,
he's picked up the one heart.
He's taken out the other one.
And he has something like--
what do you call it--
a secular epiphany,
like a religious moment.
And he just gets
on with his work,
puts the heart, releases
the cross clamp.
The heart fills with blood.
And as occasionally happens,
it just starts on its own.
And he seals up the patient.
And Cohen's got a
healthy heart in him.
And he walks out of
the operating theater
through the emergency
room still full
of horribly injured teenagers.
And there are loads of press
because of the bomb and this,
that, and the other.
And they turn, and look at
him, and ask him for a comment.
And he says, just
an hour ago, I had
the heart of an
Israeli Jew in one hand
and a heart of a Palestinian
Muslim in the other,
and there is no difference.
Now that is what brought
me to this story.
And I was making
documentaries at the time.
I was sitting in a
horrible office in London.
And I first heard
about the bomb.
Now we hear about
bombs a lot, I mean,
so much so that we are
desensitized to them.
Did you know that in
northern Syria on Wednesday
there was a bomb
in a marketplace
that killed 38 people--
worse than this one?
We just let it pass because
we can't survive that way.
And I'd been that way--
Israelis or this and that.
You just don't look at it.
They're not my people.
I'm just not going
to-- but something
about this one,
this bomb, got me,
maybe because I
was the age where
I liked going to nightclubs.
I was a DJ.
I played records here and there.
I could feel for those
people just waiting
to dance-- and just imagine
that terrible moment.
And then when I heard about the
heart transplant the next day,
it fell on me, as Larkin said--
as they say love does,
like an enormous yes,
and it gripped me.
And I'm not really telling
you the whole story.
I'm missing out a key part,
which you brought up there.
When I was a child, and I
opened the fridge in our family
house--
my three brothers and
sisters and my parents--
always on the top
shelf, generally, there
were human hearts
or bits of hearts.
And my parents weren't
serial killers.
They were cardiologists.
And we take it for granted now.
It used to be the case--
'50s, '60s-- that
the number one killer
of people in the developed
world was heart disease.
That's what knocked you off, and
because of cardiologists like
my parents-- pioneering
cardiologists--
it isn't anymore.
So just to give you a statistic,
I think 15% of children born
with heart defects in
the early '60s didn't--
only 15% made it
past into adulthood,
and now we're looking
at 90% to 95%.
So that's a very
radical change--
usually living until 70.
So that's what happened there.
And when my mother,
whose patients were
generally children lost--
when she lost a child,
she'd go and get the heart.
And she'd be with that
heart until she understood
why it had ceased to function.
On the other side as well--
so there you've
got hearts going.
All the conversations I
heard between my parents
were about aortic stenosis,
left ventricular thrombosis--
I grew up amongst that.
I saw the hearts there.
The surgeons were always
around the house smoking
furiously because it was only
in the '70s they found out
it was bad.
You know what they did when
they found out how bad it was?
All those people,
furious smokers,
they just stopped
like over night.
My dad smoked his whole life--
read one article
in "The Lancet."
He was like, this
isn't worth it.
Yeah, so then on
that side, that was
why hearts were so key to me.
On the other side,
our neighbor was
a very inspiring,
maybe even saintly,
man called Rabbi Gryn, who was
the head of the Reformed Jews
in London, and his
children were all our age.
And so we were very
close on that side.
And yet on the other side,
my father spoke Arabic.
He was an Irishman
who learned Arabic.
And my mother was
passionately involved
in the Palestinian cause.
So there were Arabs around,
there were Jews around,
there were Muslims.
People didn't know so
much, but I already
spoke 30 words of Arabic by
the time I was eight or nine.
And, you know, I still hang
out in a dishdasha jellabiya
at home.
So there were these
things so that when
I heard this news, you can
see why it gripped me so much
and became the focus of my
life, because this heart that
moved between a Palestinian
Muslim and an Israeli Jew,
it felt like to me it
could maybe heal the world.
And I just followed it.
So I went to Israel.
I went to West Bank.
I spent a long time there.
I spoke to all the people, who
were outside the Dolphinarium
who I could find.
I spoke to their brothers
and sisters, the parents.
I spoke to everyone I could.
I spent a long time there,
but there were two key things
that I needed to understand
that eluded me for a while.
One was Saeed Hotari,
this young man.
If you read all the
newspaper articles,
it said that he was a
fanatical Muslim, believed
in the whole virgins thing--
I mean, a load of
rubbish actually.
But it was this idea of this
other, then, human person
who had done this.
And he had done it for other--
fanatical reasons.
And so, I wanted to understand.
Is that who he was?
Was he a psychopath to be
able to do that appalling
thing in a bunch of teenagers?
So I needed to go and find
out, and meet his parents,
and meet everyone.
Now if you're a foreign
correspondent, the way
you will do that-- a
proper journalist, which I
have never been, but I'm
always open to an offer
from a newspaper.
What you do when you get to
somewhere like that is you
hire a fixer.
And the fixer you pay $250,
$300, $400, $500 a day.
And you tell them what you want,
and they get you the article.
They get you the interview,
and you get your quotes,
and everything moves
forward happily.
It's not what I wanted.
I mean, this is an
act of terrorism.
It comes from the Latin
terreur, I frighten.
You know, without the
aspect of performance,
it's just a violent crime.
And that aspect of
performance that comes in
is where the media
plays its part.
Not very many
newspapers, TV shows,
clicks onto stories
have been done
through the cause of peace.
Many of them are done through
the cause of fear and war.
It's not that they're cynical.
Everyone's just
getting through the day
somehow for whatever
people are interested in.
And this whole
performance activity I
wanted to get away from.
There's a sort of pattern that
happens after a terrorist bomb,
or there was.
The journalists
go to the victims,
who say what terrible--
there's such sadness and awful--
And then they go to those
family members who go,
my son or daughter is a martyr.
And then they go to--
there's a whole
[INAUDIBLE] who goes this.
I just wanted--
I wasn't after information.
I wanted a feeling type thing.
And since I'd worked in "The
Big Breakfast," Channel Four's
breakfast program years
ago, which was a TV show,
my only contact
were the people who
worked on the Palestinian
version of "Sesame Street."
So I turn up, and I'm
there, and I'm chatting.
They don't know me, but
they're really lovely.
And then after-- they're
having their production meeting
and after the production
meeting I go and ask them.
So they said, well,
how can we help you?
I said, look, I've
got this phone number.
I think it's the father
of the suicide bomber.
And I've been told I can't
call it under any circumstances
because he doesn't want
to hear an English voice.
It's going to freak him out.
So can anyone help me?
And they're all going, we
don't want any trouble.
This was a Hamas thing.
It's a dangerous area.
Everything is peaceful here.
But it turns like that.
Is there any other
element to it?
And I said, I'm not very
politically sophisticated.
I have no idea.
I'm just here.
I came on the bus.
I'm staying in the
hotel up there.
You tell me.
I just want to go and see him.
So one of them goes,
[MUMBLING] come [MUMBLING]..
They have a whole chat.
And some young guy goes--
he goes, come outside.
So we go outside.
By the way, they're having their
production meeting in a bar.
This is in Muslim Palestine.
Everyone is drinking
points of Taybeh, a beer--
a Palestinian beer.
It's just nothing is
what you expect in life.
I'm not sure what
their backgrounds are.
Anyway, we go outside.
He makes the phone call.
And he's talking.
And he goes, it's OK.
Tomorrow at 11:00, you meet him.
So I have the address.
He's written it down.
I said, by the way,
why did they ask you?
He said, everyone says I
speak Arabic beautifully.
And off he goes.
So I have this-- so
I just go in a cab.
And Qalqilya isn't the most
relaxed place in all this.
And I've got no backing at all.
I don't have a
newspaper behind me.
I don't have anything behind me.
And I don't know what
the situation is.
So my cab drive,
for instance, he
says when I get in that
he knows where it is.
And then we're driving
along, and he turns around.
He goes, where?
And I said, I don't know.
I've never been here before.
And he's seeming really antsy.
And I'm thinking, oh, my god.
What's going on here?
I was going to ask someone,
but there's no one around.
And then we see a
car, and we stop it.
And there's a black BMW,
and the guy gets out.
And I'm thinking everyone--
what's going on here?
And the guy has a chat.
And we get in, and we drive.
And then he turns around.
The driver, again
he goes, where?
I said, well, didn't
that guy tell you?
He goes, where?
I don't know.
Go.
I leave you.
And everything is
getting a bit weird.
And he seems very
anxious not to be there.
So I called the father
of the suicide bomber.
His name was Saeed
Hotari, the boy.
And his father's Abu
Hotari, father of Hotari.
And I passed it to
the taxi driver.
And they have a 10-minute chat.
And then he puts down the
phone and goes, where?
Eventually, I remember that
we passed two people standing.
And they were the
only two people.
And we're driving back
there, and we get--
and it's Abu Hotari
who is standing there.
And this guy just wants
to get paid and leave.
So I don't know if
their 10-minute chat
is driving around the block
while we sharpen the knives.
I don't know what the scenario
is at all-- or, more likely,
his wife is cooking
his favorite lunch.
He's got a guitar practice.
He can't wait to
get this job-- you
don't know in this whole thing
because one thing's for sure.
I meet him.
We have an extraordinary
few hours together,
about five or six hours.
They're not that easy because
no one speaks English.
He's asked me where I
bought my translator.
Every decent journalist
brings a translator.
I've just taken
whatever lead I've got,
and I've arrived hoping
someone would speak English.
And when he says,
where's your translator?
I lie like a child, and I go,
sorry, I thought you had one.
Like, you know, it's
like the kid, who's
meant to have done his
homework, and the teacher goes,
where's your homework?
And the kid's showing
him a blank page going,
but it was there, sir!
Anyway, we managed to
get someone to turn up,
but I spend hours in
a room with Hotari
and a guy with a scar from
here right across here--
not an injury that's done
in a domestic accident
in any way, and
not something that
makes me feel very at home.
And in the middle of the
time when we're just waiting,
I suddenly think, oh, my god,
I've got to turn off the Find
my iPad app on my iPad in case
the Israeli secret services
send a drone to get
revenge on these people.
I don't know what's
going on here.
And then at one
point, the door opens.
And there are women in the
kitchen who never come out.
And a little toddler comes out.
And the toddler's
really making everything
feel better, taking all
my dirty laundry out,
which is really
embarrassing because it's
a super clean culture.
Everyone's really nice--
And then I go [LAUGHS].
I want to show what
a nice guy I am.
Oh, yeah.
What's his name?
And Hotari goes, Osama.
And I say, oh,
that's really funny.
I think he's making
a joke or something.
He's going, no,
that is his name.
It's not a joke at all.
But actually, as
time goes on, we
end up having a really
good communication.
And I find two
important things out.
One, his son was
not particularly
religiously committed.
Two, he was also--
his father complained about
the fact that he was in no way
interested in the struggle.
He wasn't even
interested, his father
said, in Palestinian liberation.
So I said, so what
actually is causing this?
Well, it's another
whole long story
what the cause is and longer
than I can go into here.
But what was true for sure
is that the picture of him
was not accurate--
that we had received
in the press-- be it,
"The Washington Post," "The
New York Times," "The BBC."
We were given an incorrect
thing because it's too difficult
what the reality is.
And I'm not going to go
into the reality right now,
but we could, in questions,
if you wanted to.
The second thing that I
really wanted to go into,
that I really needed to know--
I was obsessed with
speaking to the guy who
had received the Palestinian
heart, Yitzhak Cohen.
Every time I tried
to find him, no one
could tell me where he was.
And normally things
were available.
And then when I spoke to the
surgeon again, and said, look,
I really want to
find Cohen, he said
he doesn't want to
speak about it at all.
He's just trying to lead
his life and get on with it.
And I said, but maybe you
could call him up for me.
And he's going, no, he
doesn't want to speak.
And then I pulled
my parent card out.
I was, by the way,
my mom is so-and-so,
and my dad is so-and-so.
And he goes, really,
the cardiologist there?
[MUMBLING] I was
going, please call.
All he can say is he can say no.
And he goes, he's
not going to do it.
And I said, Yaacov, you
put the heart in his chest.
He's going to do
whatever you ask him.
And he did.
He said, fine.
Go on.
And so, I was on my
way to go and see
Cohen, this man who had
the Palestinian heart.
And I suppose it was sort
of romantic and hippy-dippy
because--
I don't know--
I've looked at a lot of
heart transplant stories.
And I've also been at
a heart transplant.
And there's a lot of
chat about organ memory.
Are you familiar with this?
The idea that when you
transplant an organ,
its memories come with it.
And there was a
man in the US who
is 57 years old,
blue collar worker,
from a completely white area.
He knew that he'd
received the heart
of a young African-American
guy who had
been killed in a gang shootout.
That's what he knew.
But when he got the
heart, he suddenly
became obsessed with
classical music.
He became utterly obsessed
with classical music.
How was he to know that the
young African-American guy was
a violinist on his way
to violin practice, who
gets shot by a random
bullet from some maniacs
200 yards down the road?
Those sorts of things--
and there's lots of them--
made me think about
organ memory maybe being
truer than you might expect.
But then I also met [INAUDIBLE],,
one of the great heart surgeon
surgeons.
He said it's total rubbish.
He said after a
heart transplant,
you get very strong
immunosuppressant drugs.
They have a
psychotropic side effect
that changes your personality.
But then I asked a woman
called Susan Vosloo.
She's probably done more heart
transplants than [INAUDIBLE]..
And she said, oh, I don't know.
I believe it a bit.
And she told me this story
about a patient of hers
who was an incredibly shy girl
who received the heart she
didn't know of a model.
And she said afterwards
she would walk around
like she was beautiful.
And she said, look, I saw
that with my own eyes.
And then her husband, who was
in the background, [INAUDIBLE]
says, yeah, but Susan, you read
the astrology charts, yeah?
So what I mean is there's
no way of knowing,
but I was filled with, like,
a sense of what would happen.
And when I-- I'm going to
have to wrap up quickly.
I've got another 20 minutes
to go, but we kind of--
when I did see him,
he played super
nice about how wonderful it is.
I have the heart of
a Palestinian in me,
and it's all great and lovely.
And everything's
lovely, and he's
a really nice man but sick
and struggling with all that.
And a classic Sabra, it's like
an Israeli word for someone--
Sabra is a fruit with a
hard outside, spiky outside,
and really soft inside.
And that was what he
would totally direct.
But then at a certain
point I was about to leave,
and he goes, so
who's hiring you?
Which paper?
I said, I'm not a
journalist-- no paper.
What are you doing?
I said, well, I'm
writing a book.
So who is buying the book?
And I said, well, no one.
And he goes, so it's a hobby.
And it was too
close to the truth.
It's like, oh no, I'm a writer.
And I go, well no,
it's not a hobby, but--
No, it's a hobby.
You get paid.
It's real.
You know, it's a hobby.
And as soon as he
said this, he's
kind of let down his guard.
And I really wished
I'd left before then
because at some point
he said to me, this guy,
I'm fine with the Palestinians
who are here, but most of them
just want to kill Jews.
And I said, what?
The Arabs, they just
want to kill Jews.
And the Palestinians
who are here,
they're OK, but you know--
And I said, but you've got
a Palestinian heart beating
in your body.
He's going, it's a pump.
They didn't know it
was going to a Jew.
And I left.
And it felt like my whole
world was falling apart.
And when we get to
the happy event--
we don't have time for the
happy event unfortunately.
I went and saw my mom.
And my mom showed
me a photograph
of a newspaper clipping of
her in 1967 as a cardiologist.
And she's got a baby.
And it says, first heart
transplant in Britain.
And I was going, oh wow, is
that the baby who got the heart?
And she goes, no.
I said, so what's
wrong with the baby?
She said the baby eats too
much, generally very greedy.
But the baby is you.
I'm holding you outside
the first heart transplant.
And this led me to
a whole other life
where I started looking at the
first heart transplant that
ever happened, that
I'm going to have
to be very quick with, which
was in Apartheid, South Africa.
Christiaan Barnard
transplanted a heart
into a woman called Denise
Darvall into a man called
Phil Washkansky.
But what's less known
is that before that, he
was about to transplant a heart
from another man who was black.
And the Apartheid authorities
said, no, you can't do this.
Because Apartheid, or Apartheid,
what does it actually mean
is separateness.
It was a legal
representation of racism.
And in order for
it to exist there
had to be an absolute provable
difference between the races.
And so he wasn't
allowed to do it.
It's fine to do cross-gender,
not fine to cross race.
But once he'd done that,
the first heart transplant,
he became the most
famous man in the world.
And nothing could stop him.
And so, his second transplant
was between a black man
and a white man.
And suddenly, you had this
fellow, Phil Blaiberg,
with a black heart--
a heart from a black man.
And for the first
time that heart
was allowed to sit on
a whites-only bench.
For the first time, that heart
was allowed to go somewhere.
And what does that really mean?
We're moving into the symbolic.
There was a corrosive symbol of
the power of the ridiculousness
of any ideology,
especially Apartheid,
that sought to show one race
was different from another
in such a way.
And I suppose that
when it comes down
to it, what we're left with is
there are no easy solutions.
The lovely graceful symbol,
that I had sort of fell apart
in some ways, but it
sort of sticks as well--
the act of mercy of
giving the heart--
the fact that the heart can
go from one to the other--
the fact that all these
divisions are created.
They're not as
essential as that be--
I'm going to have
to stop now in case
you're not going to
have time for questions.
If there are no
questions, I could go on.
SPEAKER: I'll ask the
first question or two
before we organize into
the audience questions.
So you've described
your initial reaction
to seeing the reports
of the bombing
and your own background.
When you decided that
you needed to know more
and to research this, what
was the reaction of, like,
your publicist or your family?
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: My publisher--
I mean, my agent told me that
I shouldn't write that book
because it would have--
it wouldn't be
commercially viable.
It was too difficult
and complicated an area.
And the reality of trying
to publish this book--
it's not that easy to get a
book that's critical of Israel,
in any form, published
in the United States.
The book, I sincerely hope it's
balanced, but it wasn't saying,
oh, this is a great
idea for your--
SPEAKER: OK, they
weren't very encouraging.
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: And
reality's played that out.
SPEAKER: Yeah, OK.
You're described, in
some of your interviews,
as being maybe a little bit
naive when you're asking
certain questions of people.
And as you've just
shared with our audience
you weren't particularly
politically knowledgeable.
Do you think that
naivety served you?
Maybe you wouldn't
have done this
if you hadn't felt
being like that?
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: Well,
I don't think naivety
ever really serves you.
I think that--
I thought I went with
no preconceptions.
One of the things I realized
when I got to Israel
is that I was a little
bit anti-Israelic.
I certainly have never
been anti-Semitic,
but I realized when I was
in Israel for a few weeks--
like, hold on a minute.
And if you are anti-Israeli,
you're against that kid over
there and that
grandma over there,
and it's no better than--
it's no more acceptable
than being anti-Irish.
And so then-- because we
hear so many critical things,
and it doesn't help anyone.
There isn't a single
Palestinian, who is wise,
who wants you to
be anti-Israelic.
SPEAKER: OK, so you became
aware of your biases?
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: I became
aware of my own rubbish.
SPEAKER: All right.
Good.
So I'll ask one more question
before we go to the audience.
And if you do have
a question, hang on
till we've got a
microphone to you.
You've got my one or
one over here, I think.
So the opening
chapter of "Beats,"
that you described
in lots of detail,
the teenagers and the young
security guard that are there--
how much of what
you share with us
is based on interviews with
their family or their surviving
friends, and how much of it
is your imagination-- like,
the point of view that
you share that they--
their point of view?
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: The
opening chapter of the book
was the hardest one to
research because this
describes the teenagers
just before the bomb.
And what I did do was make sure
that nothing I said-- if they
were having a conversation
about something,
it was because
someone had told me
they'd been talking about that.
Where I mentioned
that someone had just
had an argument with her
dad about her hot pants,
it's because that happened.
Even the fluorescent colored--
SPEAKER: The nail varnish
that the grandmother--
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: --the
dreams, everything,
because for me that
part of the chapter
was the most important
because I wanted
it to be a memorial
to these people,
not as victims but as the
young humans that they
were, with their
life stolen off them.
And I still, to this
day, can't talk about it
without almost
crying because I've
got so close to them, and their
families, and all those people.
And it's worth
saying one thing that
isn't part of your question.
The aim of this bomb was to make
all those former Soviet Union
people feel that they
weren't welcome in Israel--
that this wasn't for them.
Actually what it did
was it wedded them
to the country in a
much stronger way,
and it helped create
the war that we see now.
It wasn't useful.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Have we any questions?
Oh, the front row, we
have our first question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: Hello.
AUDIENCE: And thank you for
the talk-- really interesting.
So my question was actually
about the way things
are portrayed in journalism.
So you said that the way the
suicide bomber was written
about in the media
was not really
an accurate picture of reality.
And I mean, I find that as
well when we read in the news
that sometimes you're not really
sure what to really believe
and what frame they are
putting it out there.
What do you think
about that when you,
as a writer who are
looking for the truth--
when you are reading news
stories about other attacks
or events, do you have any
pre-bias in terms of the truth
to it?
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: Of course
we all have pre-bias,
and what we have to do
is try, and analyze,
and be honest about that.
There's no getting
away from that.
But in terms of, for
instance, the way--
the idea-- one of the
big ideas was that--
was this whole thing
of the virgins.
And for me, encoded in that,
was an implicitly racist idea
of the Arab "other," this
kind of sexual deviant type
thing, which is very--
because when you create
that kind of image that
is dehumanizing, I
mean think of the kind
of Nazi anti-Semitic picture of
the kind of terrible old Jew.
It's all to make it--
take away humanity,
so that you don't deal
with the real situations.
It's a real foe
against understanding,
all those things.
Now that doesn't mean that
there isn't any basis to loads
of those things, and
especially as ISIS has shown,
there's lots of people
who do believe, you know,
in the whole thing.
But it's just the
way things are used,
it's very, very unhelpful.
And we need to get
closer to the situation--
not deal with these caricatures.
Does that answer
your question at all?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah, lovely question.
Do we have-- got one over here?
Thanks, Marie.
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: Oh, sorry.
There's two.
Can I come to you after?
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
I'm very curious
about when you went
to meet the bomber's
father, and he
said that he was
talking about his son.
And he said that his son is
A, not very political and B,
not even very religious.
And he said that there was
a long story behind it,
and maybe you can discuss
that in the questions.
Can you talk more about
this particular interaction?
How did the father
see the situation?
How did he feel?
How did you feel?
ROWAN SOMERVILLE:
The father was trying
to be, as well, the political--
there's a tremendous
thing about being--
when there's absolutely
nothing, to be
a relation of the
Shahid, the martyr,
is something that
gives you status,
and there's certain
things that--
and he was pretending to be
that person, or that persona,
for a while.
But then as time passed, he
was actually a grieving parent.
He had no idea, I believe.
[INAUDIBLE] he wasn't
in the country.
He had no idea that his
son was going to do that,
and he would have thrown himself
in front of a bus to stop it.
And in fact, the hardest
moment of questioning
happened when I saw him as a
grieving parent, and he was--
had tears in his eyes,
and I asked him, cruelly
actually, because I thought
I had a responsibility
to the parents of the victims--
I said, you feel so much
pain for your son's loss.
Do you ever think of
the mothers and fathers
of the people he's
killed because they
feel the same pain as you?
And he went mental.
And I was going to
have to kind of run.
And what was I doing?
I was like a teenager
kicking at a scar.
It didn't help anything.
It was ill-placed.
What had happened?
Now I'm not answering
your question, I'm afraid,
and that is, how did he become
a suicide bomber, really?
It's the most dangerous
question I could ask there,
and every time I did things
got really dangerous-- and even
to the point that I had to
get sort of smuggled out
of Qalqilya by someone because
I was asking that question,
and I wanted to know.
My opinion, not based on
fact, is that what happens
is that there are
professionals who
look for certain
sorts of people who
are vulnerable and available
and angry and desperate.
And they make out
of them a weapon
because they don't have
sophisticated missiles.
They have burning kites, but
what they do have access to
is the most sophisticated
guidance system
in existence, the human brain.
And what they do is make
a weapon out of that.
That's my belief.
SPEAKER: Hey, thanks Rowan.
Thank you.
That was a great question.
We're out of time unfortunately.
So just to close, what is--
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: Sorry.
SPEAKER: What's a common--
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: She
gave up her question.
SPEAKER: Well, we
can ask afterwards.
What's next for you?
Are you researching something
else, at the moment?
When can we invite
you back again
to hear about your next book?
ROWAN SOMERVILLE: I'm very
interested in religion.
I've been looking
at Scientology.
I've been looking at lots
of different of religions.
I was very much educated
a strict Roman Catholic.
I was brought up by Jesuits.
I believe that most religions
are entirely invented.
I want to examine this not
as a skeptic, not as a cynic.
And I want to write a
novel about a religion that
really works, one that really
does give you enlightenment.
SPEAKER: OK, great.
I look forward to reading it.
Thank you again for coming in
to talk with us today, Rowan.
ROWAN SOMERVILLE:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.